[Musik]
gegen
ich konnte zum 20
weil du hast du kommst du schon wieder
zu nahe warum zu nah wir sitzen
nebeneinander max nicht und david
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde gesetz bereits den titel sander
macht den führerschein
das macht sich allerdings nicht in echt
wohl machst du doch aber schon
mutter größe gehen das ist jedes mal
wird auf jeden fall wirklich im real
life seit drei jahren oder so schon
ihren führerschein kommt eigentlich so
richtig voran wir gehen heute immer
zusammen an und spielen gemeinsam den
driving school stanley hat zunächst
einmal kassel ihrem fahrzeug auswählen
vier monate hat uns nur den namen ja
aber der schools bmw abjagen kann auf
das okay aber hörte erst mal aus also
wir können ja vielleicht noch mehrere
videos hier machen wollen wir eine tag
fahrt machen oder eine nachtfahrt oder
eine überall ein fahrrad an den
überlangen fahrrad bei der nacht oder
autobahn möchte ich noch nicht optimal
märz montag vaart ja
[Musik]
slater
das ist nicht gescheitert so der
gerichte jetzt einfach mal auf neu
starten wir springen das ganze jetzt
sozusagen als allererstes sag mir doch
mal wo die hupe ist sehr gut
der stopp stopp stopp jetzt sein rad
zeig mir doch mal dass du das normale
licht anmacht das ist der linken blinker
also dann ist das sehr recht gesagt ja
ich brauche aber nicht dass
tatverdachtes fernlicht genau und werden
normales tagfahrlicht 30 ich würde sagen
genau jetzt gibt es aber jetzt annehmen
was heißt das schild da ich darf nicht
fahren
das natürlich darf sie fahren vorfahrt
gewähren richtig genau die muss warten
bis einer kommt oder die dänen dann
vorbei lassen aber genau hier kannst du
lang fahren jetzt hier darf so nicht
halten weil ihr essen hier ist im bus
aber genau da genau 30er zone wir fahren
23 km h sehr gut jetzt 50 jetzt musst du
hoch beschleunigen weil man soll ja auch
nicht zum langsamfahren und den verkehr
aufhalten
du bist du schnell die sandra da
gegenverkehr
das war aber das hat keiner gesehen hat
war einfach weiter ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt sehr geil das spiel kostet 290
die steuerung ist hardcore beschissen
aber das auto modeling also der bmw hier
sehr gut gelungen du fährst auf der
falschen straßenseite das stellt heißt
dass gleich eine ampel kommt sehen wir
nach vorne schauen wer gut es hat uns
richtig doch gedrückt aber fast
normalerweise steht man auf der straße
und nicht nehmen
man hat was gegen porsche untergebracht
ist kaum vorstellbar ganz scherb grüne
handel sank blitz wurde machen wir mal
weiter
ok also weiter geht sandra jetzt ganz
vorsichtig weil hier ist es einerseits
so dass du hier langsam drüberfahren
musste es ein zebrastreifen genau die
person vorbei gelassen und jetzt 30 km h
über das drüberfahren und jetzt wieder
auf 50 hoch aber das eingehalten zum
glück wie dieses gerät gestopft und ein
auto leisten kann es nicht wer der erste
der sagt du bist du selbst wenn du sagst
kommen lässt uns ein und wir müssen da
fünf stunden hin fange ich schaue mit
fahrrad safe alter geile mucke alter
zigarette links die flasche rechts und
wenn welche an bis zum lenkrad meine
fußnägel seit drei jahren über sein
also sage ich geb dir noch einen letzten
versuch auf dieser map hier mit diesem
auto und bei tag et cetera pp also
erstmal licht anmachen sicherheitsgurt
erstmal sich jetzt gut sehe es gut aus
susanna du fährst jetzt gerade 55 km h
es ist ein bisschen zu viel genau so gut
dass es einen baum
aber hat das ist
genau geschaut hatte scheiterte mir ja
so war im rat zweites level mehr oder
weniger als wir machen jetzt mal eine
nacht vater zeit als allererstes was
macht man nicht an richtig nicht
fernlicht das licht genau erst mal los
grau sicherheitsgurt du hast schon
wieder den blinker aber der ist gut weil
fahndeten nach vorne und dann links luca
ich habe davor nie gelingt weil ich
links und rechts abgebogen ist es mir
gerade mal so oft gefallen das stimmt
[Musik]
wie kann es überhaupt 50
erfahrungspunkte schon gesagt das ist
weg weil er den sicherheitsgurt ein
college passt soll sandra jetzt hier
links abbiegend links genau wie der
unfall gebaut
dann macht ein fernlicht an auf jeden
fall weiter hier doch der tochter denkst
du bist du hast 100 experience bekommen
weil drübergefahren
es ist allerdings nicht so schnell du
fährst gerade 60 sander bremsen von
wilma laufkarriere scheiße und einfach
freier fahren weil ich glaube karriere
mit dir es fremdwort das bisschen mehr
großstadt gerade das ein ford focus also
versucht doch mal den orangen autofahren
[Musik]
von mir für dich als aufgabe einfach
hinter dieser branche nicht auch dann
könntest wie überholen jetzt alter
richtig woran du solltest hinter ihm
bleiben habe ich gesagt das juckt mich
vielmals erstmal
was willst du
das ist voll die krasse
ich wollte immer schon so durch
deutschland flexen alter kommt gib mir
also zuallererst würde ich mal den
blinker ausmachen und ich würde trotzdem
nicht an machen ja auch am tag
das heißt ich weiß hier langsam 40 km h
s ok hier ist 50 das heißt falls hier so
ein bisschen zu gut eine nummer die
linke hier deswegen fahre ich jetzt nach
rechts man darf sich nicht von rechts
überholen aber wir wollen ein bisschen
schneller fahren april wird gelb das
heißt ich brenne schon mal langsam war
nach vorne neben den audi und warten
die ampel ist grün geworden
das heißt ich bin jetzt langsam rechts
ab schulterblick hab ich ja gerade schon
gemacht also da kommt auf jeden fall
keiner
[Musik]
da saßen wir sehen mir war es so schön
als ich gefahren was auf der echten
porsche sind okay wenn wir jetzt mal ein
wer so eine wenn die einen mitnehmen und
sagt ich muss hier raus also nein
ehrlich geht es genau in den porsche ja
nur weil die porsches markt es mag aber
nur umgehst würde ich niemals zugab
vorreiter demnächst auch straßenposten
der weg geflext wir leben im alter
[Musik]
bringt
sie spülte die ganze zeit so wäger es um
berichte gewicht also jetzt hab ich
endlich mal gelenkt wurde jetzt mit
vollen 100 km h und porsche ich habe
warum bist du so recht in die bande
gekracht weil sie meine lieben freunde
ihr seht schon wir sind jetzt auf map
fünf von den fünf maps die wir haben
bisher haben wir nur mehr 1 und 2
gespielt gerade befinden wir uns auf der
autobahn wieder mit unserem bmw und
sandra fährt jetzt einfach mal ich sage
du schaffst ebensee kolonne unfall
bei 34 56
die sache ist allerdings wer es trotzdem
einmal durchgefallen weil du gerade mit
30 km h über die autobahn gefahren bist
und dann muss man mindestens 80 fahren
echt wirklich so einfach so
wusstet ihr dass ich mal beim fahrrad
auf einer autobahn gefahren
wir schauen uns jetzt einmal die vierte
der fünf maps an
ich glaube das sieht so aus wie ein
hangar oder wie ein industriegebiet
zumindest dachte solche straße
ich sehe diesen jetzt gerade arbeiten
und dann muss ich dann meinen amg
vorbeifahrenden bmw in meinen träumen
ist alles angeht machen
so kann ich heute gegen den gewinn hatte
die map ist auch nichts für dich gibt ja
so war die letzte map die wir haben sind
wir doch gleich in österreich gelandet
ja okay wir sind jetzt mit sandra in
österreich das heißt du fährst jetzt
einfach über die straße ist komplett
leer ich bin du musst jetzt nicht die
ganze zeit längst fest jetzt einfach
erst mal geradeaus ja schon hand am
steuer
und jetzt stoppschild übersehen 90 aber
egal gehen es kann jetzt 96 dafür ihr
davon der weiße autos bahnen war es lass
mich dadurch junge dürften mit mir weißt
du gar nicht fassen kann auf dem feld
weiter vermindert thema anwalt noch
komplett zu flicken so viel zu pflücken
in diesem fall firma kurz hier mit
goethe statur mit goethe statur
es ist hier schon wieder eine reinste
katastrophe sondern ist die durch sei
noch immer so rum drehst wenn du denkst
du fertig bist du überhaupt um einen
gott sein oder was noch nie so lange
halten
ja aber bist du gegen den berg gefahren
[Musik]
ja wir können schaffen
jahrhundert ja wenn ich mit 100 km/h im
echten leben gegen einen baum diese dann
schaffe ich es nicht oder wird es ja
zunächst zu mir ich gratuliere dir zu
nicht bestandenen prüfungen die knapp
100 prozent ich bestanden weil die 100
km/h quote geknüpft an dem leben also
deiner meinung nach schafft man den
führerschein wenn mannschaft 100 km h zu
fahren
ok mit der aussage will ich sagen wenn
wir das heutige video wenn ihr wollt
dass sein und ich noch mal irgendwie
einen normalen fahrstuhl tests machen
vielleicht mit fragen oder irgendwie so
oder vielleicht doch echt mal zusammen
auf dem lukrativen lukas porsche fahren
auf keinen fall lasten like da abonniert
main kanal
[Musik]